1090. This time it was Charlemagne's empire that crumbled. And with it his dream of free and educated men. Roads were unsafe. Travelers needed protection from the most powerful landlords, barons, and abbots. The feudal era had begun.
Quick! Take it, my lord! Take it!
What a lucky day! Let's go!
Watch out, you're getting my feet out wet! I can't even get near enough to throw water on it, it's too hot!
Hooray for fire, hooray for fire, hooray for fire, hooray for fire, hooray for fire, hooray for fire, hooray for fire.
Oh, it's that pretty nice looking fire. Yeah, it's quite a show. I'll show you a show or two, you bumpkin. And you, get moving and fight the fire, nitwit.
Ah, why bother now? He's here. The Lord, the man of art, is just arrived. Patience, my friend. Look here, the very latest in dungeons.
Julie, it's not bad. Up there, you've doubled the center beam. It's useless, but at least it looks like it.
Huh?
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait! I have an effort!
Get to work! Make it quick!
Now then, you see, it's starting to take shape! I told you so!
But tell me, what's this weird shape it's in?
I don't like it that way!
Well then, how's that? Tell me what you think?
Are this any better, huh?
Yeah, well, sure!
I mean, I've told you and told you to keep to my plans, imbecile!
Can't you see this dungeon's leaning sideways?
The hired help ain't what it used to be!
Hey, you down there!
You don't look too stupid, come give me a hand!
Sure.
There, all set. Just make sure the scaffolding's nice and straight.
Good, let's get on with it.
Your horse is ready, my lord. We can leave now.
I'm a-hunting, we will go.
Get along, little doggie.
Yep, yep.
Mama.
The collars on those oxen are too tight.
Perhaps we ought to be able to do something about that.
Ah, nice little beastie.
Mmmmm.
Now take a look what happened.
Gah!
Well then, perhaps like this. Reinforcing the girth.
Oh no. That won't work. We'll have to think of something else, drat it.
What seems to be the trouble, my lord?
The trouble is my numbskull here at Rotter escaped and be of service.
I believe that this time you'll be satisfied with my work.
I hope so for your sake.
Pretty good we'll be able to spot rich travelers.
Hey boss, it's not bad, eh?
Bigs all around.
Oh, you see what I see down there on the road?
All right, Glass, the settlement where we can hope to find safety.
Let's push on quickly, my friends.
Seemed like a decent lad. You should come to this city. I'll find you an interesting job.
Grif and some other serfs have escaped and are trying to reach the city in a better life.
They're after us. Hide all of you.
You'll make a run for it, huh?
You won.
The nobles were busy adding to their property and profits.
At that time, the late 11th century, the clergy did likewise.
But it was the townsfolk, protected by their walls of stone, who started to think free thoughts.
This would come as quite a surprise for our young friend.
Ah, my good heart, it lad a penny for the poor.
But I have nothing.
For my brother's supper is ready.
What rich fabric.
And those gems.
It's all so beautiful.
Oh, the city's really interesting.
That is, depending on what you find interesting.
Why, sure it's interesting.
The proof. Good day.
Good day, stranger.
Ah, my newest project.
Here, study the blueprint.
The basilica will be cross-shaped,
formed by the intersection of the nave and choir with the transepts.
And I won't hear of making low vaults.
I want them to surge upward, towards heaven.
May I have a look?
According to my figures, with flying buttresses, it ought to work.
And yet, according to my figures...
Are you all right?
Thanks for everything, Claret.
I think I'm going to have to use new figures.
If it falls down, that means it can't hold up.
If it can't hold up, that means it lacks support.
Support, support, support, support!
Eureka!
Buttresses, my boy, buttresses, that's the answer.
Do you hear me?
I somehow get the feeling he doubts me.
Boy, now listen, this time I'm sure.
Must be doing it on purpose, devise all reason.
My boy, you all right?
As you can see, couldn't be better.
I'm just fine.
holiness has just decreed a crusade against the infidels guardians of the tomb of christ
these are his words go my sons do battle and vanquish the pagans it is god's will
yes my friends it's god's will to jerusalem to jerusalem god wills it hey friend how's it going
i prefer to stay as far as go on get moving besides i have my work to finish up not to
mention the most important of my reasons. Oh, yeah, I see what you mean. Forward march. In the service of God, forward march. Not a single Western monarch took part in that first glorious call to the Crusades. All three, William II of England, Henry IV of Germany, and Philip I of France, had been excommunicated by the irascible Pope Urban II. Years have passed since the First Crusades set out. In the town, life goes on, peacefully. People sleep without a stitch on, but surprisingly take their baths fully dressed. Rather, skimpy baths and
best say hello to baby sister be good my children till tonight this morning there's a great commotion
in the public square peter the hermit has returned hey and so i humbly ask of god the father have we
erased our sin time goes by and one fine day we must never forget the day we surrounded those
savages and gave them a good wish they're back see old pal we ended a full battle 15,000 strong
After a few minor points were discussed, we succeeded in convincing our adversaries to see it our way.
Finally, it was me that raised our flag over the fortress at Jerusalem.
Now that you've become a free man, you'll be able to stay here and help us.
Oh, man, what a cute little poultry vendor.
She's cute, sure, but I'm afraid, sir, you're not exactly what I call her type.
Look at yourself, a little chubby round the gills, wouldn't you say?
Oh, she loves me, she loves me not.
She loves me, she loves me not.
I'll be arrested for indecent exposure at the least. I'll catch the grip.
He loves me. He loves me not. He loves me.
Come on, Lursh. You get your hands off that poor beast.
All of an animal's strength lies in the shoulder and neck.
Anything it wears in that area must not choke the beast.
But what is the best thing?
Well, maybe a stiff collar.
Huh?
Now, put on your thinking cap, my boy.
The animal would hurt itself with a stiff collar.
Stiff.
No, no. Impossible, Steph. What a crazy idea.
What's crazy about my idea, seems to me it's better than yours up to now.
Today is a holiday. Everyone's off work, so they can go to the tournament.
And one of the adversaries is none other than...
Give him a good licking.
Then it's time for school.
Rosé Rosa.
What is the name of this country?
My son.
I've got it. That's it. Take a look.
I told you so. The solution is a stiff shoulder collar.
This will certainly be one of the century's great finds.
From now on, my name will be passed on to posterity.
Do you realize my invention will pave the way for cargo, transport, trade?
My invention means a better life.
Everyone will benefit.
Do you realize what all this means?
They've stolen my idea.
Some people are truly unscrupulous.
I certainly agree.
Several decades have passed.
Grandchildren have grown up.
Yet another crusade has set out only to come back defeated.
Cities have gained full freedom.
There is a university open to everyone, free of charge.
Theology, canon law, dialectics, the arts, and medicine are taught by masters such as Albert the Great of Germany, Thomas Aquinas from Italy, Abelard from Paris, and Roger Bacon the Englishman.
Today one of Burt's grandchildren is receiving his diploma.
It was God's will, the will of God, and none shall dare oppose the will of God.
And on this very spot, with the consent of all, we shall construct a great house for the people, a cathedral where all may come to pray, where none shall be refused refuge.
Is that not a glorious thought? Is not all.
I have more news.
One moment.
We have here among us two great builders.
The people enthusiastically set to work.
Certainly aren't wasting any time.
Oh, steady on the winch.
My, they are enthusiastic, aren't they?
Hey, what's that mess you're making?
What's it good for?
Nothing, that's what.
They work with rare dedication.
Not too bad, but it looks too new.
Only a complete utter idiot would damage that work of art.
Now it looks much more antique.
Oh, I can't believe it.
To daddy.
Say hello to your daddy.
Start the hoist now.
Guys, ready up there?
Persecrate the Holy Land, everyone join up for the new crusade.
Let's not permit pagans to touch the tomb of Christ.
We'll be back soon.
Lurch, take care of my oldest son.
All right, I'll show him what I think of heathens.
Outside the city of Acre, the troops of Philip Augustus, king of France,
were joined by those of Richard, king of England.
Well, my friends, we've got bad news, sir.
Well, let me have it.
The emperor Barbarossa is dead.
He had just laid siege to Korea, capital of Armenia, when he decided to go swimming.
Alas, he got cramps.
what shall we do we shall have to continue besieging aqua richard come what may good now
we no longer have enough men we better attack yeah you're right let's sound the call to combat
suddenly from the mountains comes the laden's army to save the besieged city no way we can
attack now camps were pitched on either side of the ramparts lookouts were posted and between
skirmishes the armies fraternized a no-man's land was created complete with shops more than
seven thousand of them there was haggling bartering swords for liquor coats of mail for
goats there were even wild parties how can we do battle when we're so outnumbered various tactics
were reviewed finally a desperate attack was launched crusaders flag flew over acra by the
time king philip of france made his farewells you have done your duty philip richard ii continued
on towards jerusalem where he earned his nickname richard the lionhearted crusaders reached jerusalem
richard didn't dare lead an attack the walls were too strong and his army was surrounded by
saladin's men the besiegers ran too great a risk of becoming the besieged and so his troops laid
down their arms and set up camp. One day at dawn, while the crusaders slept, Richard and some of
his cavaliers had time to don their arms, lead an attack. After hours and hours of combat, Richard
and his horse had more arrows than a porcupine has quills. His exhausted steed fell at last.
On September 3rd, 1192, Richard and Saladin signed a peace treaty granting the Christians free access
to the Holy Land. Richard the Lionhearted committed himself to another expedition later on to win
back Jerusalem. His new friend Saladin replied, if I must lose my land, then I'd rather lose it to you
than to any other man in the world.
The years go by.
Bert's children carry on his work.
His grandchildren, in turn, do their share.
Generation succeeds generation, and the walls grow higher.
The cathedral is nearing completion.
Listen to me, my brethren, a new crusade.
The infidels have once again soiled the Holy Land.
Listen to me, the infidels have once again soiled the Holy Land, my friends.
Thank you for the cathedral.
Yes, what we'll have to do is prop it up.
Let's talk man to man.
Trips, you know, make boys into men.
Very well, we accept your enlistment.
Eureka! I found it!
Yippee!
Got it! My system's really perfect this time. Let's try it.
Hey, up there, take it easy!
It's really up to snuff.
Or almost.
What?
Nothing serious, bleeding, and powder of staghorn.
Staghorn?
Not so fast. That customer's blind.
Ah, right. Sometimes one gets confused to watch it.
There's one that's still alive. This one's for me.
Master, will you come see our offerings for the cathedral?
Look, can't you see? I'm...
Yeah, I'm up to my...
I have to my neck at work.
Oh, wait a second.
My statue is rather impressive, Oscar.
Out this fabric. Feel it, if you please.
I'm sure there's remarkable Madonna.
He's finally done stained glass window.
What a marvelous ensemble.
Snow is flamboyant gothy.
See, it's solid.
I was right after all.
Then an eco-host mural.
Are they possible?
Brethren, enter my brethren.
I'm here to the house of the Lord.
Enter my brethren.
Cathedral, the house of the people, was at last complete in all its splendor.
There would be a few more crusades.
One of them made the mistake of attacking the Catholic city of Constantinople and looting it.
The last crusade ended with the fall of Christianity's last bastion, St. John of Acre in 1291,
and so ended what Pope Urban II had begun two centuries earlier.
And whether God willed it or no, the era of the crusades inspired Europe
to some of her finest achievements in church architecture.